A
POLITICAL PRICE TO PAY FOR
THAT.
COME NOVEMBER.
JOINING US NOW TEXAS
CONGRESSMAN MIKE McCAUL
WHO SERVES ON FOREIGN
AFFAIRS AND HOMELAND
SECURITY, MAYBE MY CIVICS IS
WRONG.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE THE
HOUSE AND SENATE AND WHITE
HOUSE, WHY DO THEY NEED YOUR
HELP TO FIX THE IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM?
>> THEY DON'T.
YOU KNOW THAT.
HAPPY EASTER.
I THINK, THEY -- THIS ISSUE
WAS FIXED.
IN THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION.
I WORKED WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S TEAM TO GET MIGRANT
PROTECTION PROTOCOLS IN
PLACE REMAIN IN MEXICO, THAT
WORKED.
IT WAS STOPPING THE -- YOU
KNOW IF YOU HAVE A TRUE
POLITICAL ASYLUM, YOU CAN
GET IN, BUT 85% AS YOU KNOW,
ARE NOT.
THEY REMAIN IN MEXICO, IT IS
STOPPED THEM FROM COMING IN,
THEN, ONCE THEY GET IN, IT
IS WATCH AND RELEASE ALL
OVER AGAIN.
THEY RESCINDED THE POLICIES
FROM DAY ONE.
THEY OWN THIS.
IN TERMS OF MIDTERM
ELECTIONS THEY OWN IT, THEY
CAN FIX IT, BUT THEY DON'T
WANT TO.
TREY: ALL RIGHT CONGRESSMAN
YOU LIVE IN A BORDER STATE,
THE GREAT STATE OF TEXAS,
FOR THOSE OF US WHAT DON'T
LIVE WITH THIS ON A DAILY
BASIS, TELL US HOW THE
BORDER HAS DETERIORATED FROM
LEST COUPLE YEARS?
>> YOU HAVE ALMOST I DON'T
KNOW ESTIMATES OF 2 TO 3
MILLION THAT HAVE COME IN
UNDER THIS ADMINISTRATION.
WITH TITLE 42, THAT WILL BE
SUSPENDED IN MAY, THEY ARE
PROJECTING 500,000 ILLEGALS
COMING IN IN 5 WEEKS.
YOU WERE A FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR, YOU CAN MOTTE
SUSTAIN THIS.
NOT TO MENTION THE FENTANYL
COMING IN, WE HAVE SEIZED
ENOUGH TO KILL THE ENTIRE
POPULATION AT THE BORDER 7
TIMES OVER WITH FENTANYL, IT
IS KILLING OUR KIDS.
OUT THERE.
NOT TO MENTION THE CRIMINALS
THAT COME IN.
THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
PHENOMENON.
THIS IS PROBABLY THE BIGGEST
HUMAN TRAFFICKING EVENT OF
OUR LIFETIME, IT DIDN'T HAVE
TO HAPPEN, THAT IS THE
SADDEST THING ABOUT THIS
SITUATION, I'M IN A
BORDER STATE, WE HAVE TO
ABSORB THIS, BUT I WOULD
ARGUE EVERY STATE IS A
BORDER STATE, THEY ARE NOT
JUST STAYING IN TEXAS, THEY
ARE MOVING ON.
EVERY STATE IN THE COUNTRY
WILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH THIS
PROBLEM.
TREY: THAT IS YOUR HOMELAND
SECURITY ASSIGNMENT.
NOW FOREIGN AFFAIRS, THE WAR
IN EASTERN EUROPE IS
CREATING A GENERATION OF
REFUGEES.
THEY ARE FLEEING A GENOCIDE,
LISTEN TO THE PRESIDENT AND
RESPOND.
>> NONE OF US IT SHOULD
HINGE ON WHETHER A DICTATOR
DECLARES WAR AND COMMITTING
GENOCIDE A HALF A WORLD
WALKER.
>> YES, I CALLED IT GENOCIDE
IT IS CLEARER AND CLEARER,
THAT PUTIN IS
TRYING TO WIPE OUT THE IDEA
OF EVEN BEING UKRAINIAN.
TREY: A LOT OF PEOPLE CALL
IT A GENOCIDE SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE WAR.
IT IS ALWAYS BEEN A
GENOCIDE TO SOME OF US. US.
>> OF COURSE, RUSSIA IS
TRYING TO EXTERMINATE THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE.
LAST FALL -- THE
INTELLIGENCE SHOWED THAT
HITTING CIVILIANS WAS PART
OF THE BATTLE PLAN FROM DAY
ONE.
WE SAW THE BOMBING OF THE
MATERNAL HOSPITAL AND THE
WOMAN WHO HAD HER BABY
WHEELED OUT, AND THEY
UNFORTUNATELY DIDN'T MAKE
IT.
AND CHILDREN WE COULD SEE
FROM AERIAL SATELLITES
BOMBED BY THE RUSSIANS AND
THE BOMB TO THE TRAIN
STATION, THIS IS NOT ONLY
GENOCIDE BUT A WAR CRIME,
THEY BILL, WAR CRIME BILL
PASSED HOUSE FLOOR TO GO TO
SENATE TO CALL IT WHAT IT
IS.
WE GOT TO GATHER THE
EVIDENCE OF THE WAR CRIMES
TAKING PLACE RIGHT NOW.
MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS TAKEN
TO AN INTERNATIONAL
TRIBUNAL.
WHERE VLADIMIR PUTIN AND ALL
OF HIS CRONIES WILL BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE.
TREY: I'LL LET YOU GO WITH
IT AT SOME POINT, THERE IS A
DESIRE TO PLAY OFFENSE.
IS THERE ANY APPETITE THAT
YOU CAN DETECT IN THE
CONGRESS FOR SENDING
OFFENSIVE WEAPONS?
WEAPONS THAT WOULD HELP
UKRAINE PRESS THE ISSUE AS
OPPOSED TO PLAYING DEFENSE?
>> IN CONGRESS FOR SURE.
THIS IS ALMOST BIPARTISAN.
IN THE ADMINISTRATION, I
PLEADED WITH THEM LAST
NOVEMBER, I SIGN OFF ON THE
FOREIGN MILITARY WEAPON
SALES, THEY HELD THEM UP
LAST NOVEMBER, THEY HAD TO
WAIT UNTIL AFTER AN EVASION
TO MAKE IT HAPPEN, NOW WE'RE
TRY TOKING CATCH UP -- WE'RE
TRYING TO CATCH UP, I SAW, A
LOT OF UNMARKED 18-WHEEL
TRUCKS MOVING IN FROM POLAND
TO UKRAINE CARRYING A LOT OF
WEAPONS.
THEY NEED THE ANTIAIRCRAFT.
THEY NEED ANTISHIP.
IDEA THAT UKRAINIANS COULD
DOWN ONE OF THE BIGGEST
WARSHIPS THAT RUSSIA HAS IN
THE BLACK SEA, WHO WOULD
HAVE THOUGHT THIS.
WE WERE TOLD IT WOULD BE
OVER IN 4 DAYS, THEY COULD
ACTUALLY WIN THIS WAR IF WE
WOULD PROPERLY EQUIP THEM.
I WAS WITH SECRETARY BAKER
LAST NIGHT.
WE TALKED ABOUT WHAT WOULD
REAGAN DO.
HIS RESPONSE WAS, HE WOULD
HAVE DONE A LOT MORE AND A
LOT SOONER.
TREY: I DON'T DOUBT IT, IF
ANYONE WOULD KNOW IT WOULD
BE JAMES BAKER, THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US, HAPPY EASTER
TO YOU AND YOUR FAMIL